ampa receptors are one type of
ionotropic glutamate receptors and they
are found in the excitatory synapses
where they regulate postsynaptic
potentials
ampa stands for alpha amino 3 hydroxy 5
methyl 4 isoxa propionic acid
so a mouthful of term
anyway
this particular thing is abbreviated as
ampa and which is a agonist for this
particular receptor and the receptor is
named after its agonist
this video is about
what are ampa receptors
electrophysiological features of ampa
receptors and receptor subtypes if you
haven't yet subscribed hit that
subscribe button and use headphone for
better quality
we can find ampa receptors in the
glutamatergic synapse where we can see
them at the postsynaptic density
under glutamate receptors there are many
ionotropic and metabotropic receptors
like ampa receptors kinetic receptors
and nmda receptors all of these are
ionotropic receptors simply meaning they
are ligand-gated ion channels
and the metabotropic glutamate receptors
are known as mglu are
so all these uh metabotropic receptors
use second messengers and other
intermediate players for functioning
in this video we are going to focus on
the ampa receptor only
so ampa receptors are glutamate
receptors they are ligand-gated ion
channels they regulate synaptic strength
and important for synaptic plasticity
let's look at the glutamatergic terminal
to understand the function of ampa
receptors here the presynaptic
action potential has reached the synapse
which lead to glutamate release in the
synaptic cliff
now in the post-synaptic in the post
synapse there is ampa receptors upon
glutamate binding
the opening of ampa receptor leads to a
conduction of cations inside the post
synapse
which leads to a positive potential
in the postsynapse
and this leads to the postsynaptic
response
in order to understand ampa receptor
kinetics more we need to understand the
electrophysiological parameters
so we would be performing a whole cell
recording in a voltage clamp mode if you
don't understand what is a whole cell
configuration or voltage clamp you can
click on the video in the i button
anyway here we would be injecting a
specific holding the particular cell in
specific voltage and measure the current
so we can look at the current traces
like this
another way of looking at it is plotting
a iv and conductance versus voltage plot
so this particular graph is transformed
into this iv plot which shows a linear
pattern let me tell you what this linear
pattern means but before that let me
tell you the conductance versus voltage
plot it's pretty much flat that means it
has no voltage dependence which is
pretty expected because ampa receptors
are ligand-gated ion channels they are
not voltage-gated ion channels so why
they should be dependent on voltage
anyway
this part of the the graph
shows the inward current at negative
voltage that means simply in the
negative voltage range the ampere
receptor conducts current which is
inward direction and that is reflected
in the current traces as well but in the
pos in the positive voltage the current
direction is changed and it is outward
anyway
if we look at the conductance it clearly
shows the conductance is not changing
with respect with the change in voltage
we can compare this with a nmda receptor
which is another another glutamatergic
receptors ionotropic glutamate receptor
so nmd receptor shows its iv plot like
this and gv plot like this so we can
clearly understand almost no current is
present in negative voltage whereas a
little bit of current is present when
the membrane potential becomes slightly
more positive
and there is outward current at positive
voltage similarly there is no
conductance in negative voltage
so nmda receptor shows a voltage
dependent kinetics
anyway if we superimpose both these
curves in one graph they would look like
this in red we have nmda profiles and in
green we have amp receptor profiles
what would we do with this data or this
understanding if our
electrophysiologists want to record ampa
currents and get rid of nmda currents
for a moment then they need this kind of
information let me tell you how so here
we are again doing a voltage clamp
recording so we are giving one
millimolar glutamate pulse for one
millisecond and we are recording at 60
millivolts plus 60 millivolts so we will
get amper current as well as nmda
current marked in rate
now if we hold it at minus 60 millivolt
we would definitely get amper current
as we can see from the iv plot but we
won't get any nmda current so holding it
at a negative voltage
would ensure
that we get rid of the nmda current and
we can purely isolate the amper current
now if we record in two parameters
the minus 60 millivolt will give you
pure ampa current
and the plus 60 would give you a
combined current in mda plus ampere now
once you know the value of ampere you
can also know what is the nmda current
as well
so all these physiological parameters
can be understood using these iv plot
and that's why it is super important let
us quickly compare amp and nmd receptors
so ampa conducts sodium and potassium
whereas nmda conducts calcium as well
both of these channel has a reversal
potential of 0 millivolt the conductance
is much more in case of nmda receptors
which is 50 picoseconds picoseconds
which is 10 times higher than the ampere
receptors the current kinetics is also
different
for example the ampa shows a very fast
opening and closing kinetics
whereas the nmda shows a sustained
current kinetics
now ampa and nmd are kind of
interdependent when there is a glutamate
release in the postsynaptic cleft the
ampa receptor opens and allows cations
to influx
at this point of time nmd receptors are
not really active that means even if
glutamate binds to the nmda receptor
they are really not conductive due to
this magnesium block but when certain
amount of
sodium sodium or other cations influx
through the ampa receptors the membrane
inside becomes positive which repels
this
magnesium ion out of these nmda receptor
that allows the influx of cations
through the nmda receptor so moral of
the story ampa and nmd receptors are
kind of interdependent let's look at the
ampa receptor subunits
these ampa receptor subunits are known
as glue a4 to glue a1 they are encoded
by gria one to four gene
the most common one is basically glue a2
ampere subunit and this shows a linear
iv curve as expected
the non blue a2
subunit containing ampa receptor shows a
inward rectifying
profile that means they conducts current
only in the inward direction not in the
outward direction
now these particular channels could be
hetero tetramer or homo tetramer glue a
one homo tetramer glue a two homo
tetramer three or four homo tetramer can
be found in many synapses blu-ray two is
the most common one in case of
heterotetramers
at least one combination has to be glue
a2 that means there could be glue a 4
hetero tetramer glue a 2 3
hydroelectromagnet or glued to one
heterotectroma
we won't find glue a 1 3 heterotetramer
generally
so in this video we have discussed what
are ampa receptors
we looked at they are ligand-gated ion
channels they show no voltage dependence
because they are elongated ion channels
they regulate synaptic activity
especially the post-synaptic potential
then we looked at the
electrophysiological properties of ampa
receptors and compared them with nmg
if you like this video
don't forget to share with your friends
get notes and flash cards in my facebook
page and instagram all the links are
provided in description you can support
my channel using patreon or beam upi app
under each video there is an option for
super thanks in the bottom right corner
of the video you can pay using paytm and
paypal your small contribution means a
lot for me you can connect with me via
social media all the links are in the
description you can support the nerd
medic channel and subscribe to his
channel all the links are provided in
the description as well